people are scared
I mean look at your face would you get
in the finals a favor sure what got her
here when you have the chance
and those in nominees for best mobile
game on Gabe spots game of the year 2014
all right nice breath their games which
could come out on consoles and PCs games
which are very much handheld phone games
and in games you can basically play on
whatever platform you want just totally
indicative of the whole mobile
experience I'm yes you know the it's
sort of it casts a huge net so this
category is tough to like sort of narrow
it down because people play on different
sized mobile devices in different in so
many different ways that's what makes it
a really cool but this used to be best
phone game like that's what you think of
you think of Oh games I could play there
because we've already got categories for
stuff like 3ds and Vita so they're not
in here this is more like tablets and
whatnot but they're so many ways to play
these games I'm one of the games which
is arguably played on pc as much as it
is a mobile devices is hearthstone and
that's one of the arguments that we
talked a lot about is is this a an award
for a game that you are gonna play while
you're waiting or is this a game that
like with hearthstone where you're
sitting at home and this is an
experience where you need Wi-Fi and it's
a very in-depth like this isn't
something that you're just playing the
past the time when you get into
hearthstone it is it is an all
knock-down drag-out fight to win over
your opponent and Blizzard just does
such a great job of making a
free-to-play game feel like it has so
much behind it it doesn't feel like just
a kind of a quick Cashin it feels like
they put all of the love of all of their
the blizzard properties all of the
Warcraft properties behind it an
incredible depth of the decks people
build and the strategic interplay and
how even this week how fired up everyone
is getting about the new updates and the
new cards and stuff like that it's it's
just incredible hearthstone definitely a
strong contender in our nominees this
year and a completely different type of
mobile experience as sort of a personal
and one you'd play I guess will be sort
of in your bed just before sleep is how
I've been playing it and Monument Valley
yeah so I I have I don't really like to
distinguish the mobile games that way
personally like yeah maybe that's
where you play it maybe hearthstone is
like a bigger experience but I think my
news valley is not like it stands but it
stands on its own for the quality of its
art for the inventiveness of its levels
and its atmosphere and I hate to say
like oh it's one of the best games that
you would just play like on the bus it's
writing like you don't qualify no I
don't want to I think it's a great game
that happens to be on mobile and is one
is like a really unique artistic
experience that you mean even on any
platform would be great you know it
doesn't have to be mobile and one of the
things we're used to on mobile games is
as companies taking established
franchises and then sort of making
mobile versions of them which are either
terrible copycats of the core gameplay
of the actual game or just throw away
nonsense or like a companion app yeah
something like that it turns out hit
mango is actually pretty great I know
there was such a surprise that when they
announced him and go I thought it would
just kind of be something that's a
throwaway like you're not gonna want to
play it but they take that that hitman
aesthetic and they put it into a like a
board game wrapper and it makes you feel
like you're playing hitman but from the
point of view of playing a board game
and it's you're still using stealth and
you're still using well in some cases
use stealth but you're you have to use
your brain in ways that hitman always
challenges you that you're not just
looking for that the most direct route
out of someplace you want to assassinate
your targets or get out stuffily without
being found it is this really
fascinating distillation of that formula
and you almost imagine that like maybe
the game designers this is like how they
work out level design for a full five
Man game right alright so in the in the
in the tennis club level we're gonna
have these pathways and stuff like that
and so charged or something but yet but
the the sort of mental challenge is
still there but even when you break it
down and the making it into a board game
also makes it look really good like if
you tried to make a full hitman game on
tablet it probably wouldn't come across
as well as getting to make these little
like handcrafted characters that you're
moving around on a really cool looking
game board and this is the guy who has
like tons of amoebas on his yeah good
point yeah another game which a lot of
folks in our meetings or at least these
types of games to be playing on pc or on
console and the wolf among us has made
it onto the nominees list for best
mobile game what do you think it is
about the wolf among us that gets it
into this category i think this is one
of the
this game is sort of indicative more
than and you know like hearth stone of
this sort of a parody of experience
between mobile console pc not that every
experience is going to be the same but
that like the quality heights you can
reach uh are equal across the board and
i think wolf among us is a game that a
lot of people in our discussions enjoyed
on console and enjoy it on pc and enjoy
it on mobile and so it's sort of you
know that becomes part of the discussion
as well like how does it get there but i
think you know the way that this is the
story focused aspect the episodic aspect
really make it like a book you read
before you go to bed like it fills that
kind of place niche or like I'm sitting
out on the porch I'm playing it and I
don't like mobile discussions are kind
of hard to divorce from where you are
when you're playing it but I think no
matter where you are with a wolf among
us it draws you in because that world is
so unique because what they do with the
world is so fascinating and honestly
personally I didn't really like episode
one hmm it didn't really jive with my
enjoyment of the fables franchise in
graphic novel form but then I think over
the course of the season they just
developed it into something really
really I'm one of the best things that
it was actually get those chapters out
in relatively quick succession as well
which is not something tell tale of I've
always done and I guess our last nominee
I that I can hear the chat already why
isn't 2048 in there why did threes make
the cut well rules the original know so
yeah and you're arguing for 2048 you
you're just completely in the wrong
threes or that they made this idea 2040
is not only easier but it's not as much
fun it's not as lovingly crafted as
threes is I mean when you look at the
the little art for the card characters
they made it so it's adorable that's so
cool yes horns and wings but I threes is
definitely the more traditional phone
game when you think of like I'm gonna
play something I phone this is the thing
you do to pass the time but it draws you
in the more you play it the more you
learn what those strategies are and that
there is more than your goodness you're
not just randomly sliding things around
on the board there's a definite order to
this chaos there's that thinking ahead
move after move and like anticipating
what's coming next and sometimes you
know what it's going to be but other
times you're like playing probabilities
and based on your previous experience
and that
you get into the whole leaderboard
battle with marckwald in the UK we got a
six-figure score some of a pack yeah but
I mean the amount i think that threes is
one of the few games for me that is
responsible for me missing a stop on my
train right yeah awesome yeah great
that's an interesting five nominee is
going to be really interesting to see
who wins that one December 11th on
gamespot com is when we'll be announcing
the winner of our best mobile game